[Musique]
et ce matin nous recevons le père
patrick desbois bonjour merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes président de
l'association internationale de yahad in
unum coordinateur scientifique du
mémorial de babi yar à kiev vous
travaillez sur la shoah par balles
l'assassinât d'un million et demi de
juifs en ukraine entre 1941 et 1944
depuis que les troupes russes ont quitté
après des semaines d'occupation des
villes de la région de kiev pour se
consacrer à l'offensive dans l'est de
l'ukraine les découvertes macabres se
succèdent la russie est accusé par
l'ukraine d'avoir commis des crimes de
guerre et des crimes contre l'humanité
volodymyr zelensky le président
ukrainien dénonce aussi un génocide
alors si on s'attarde sur ce qui s'est
passé à haïr pinet habbouch à ces villes
qui sont situés à la périphérie de kiev
1 des centaines de corps ont été
retrouvés dans des fosses communes mais
aussi abattus et laissés dans la rue
c'est certes un témoignage par
d'exécution et vous avez entrepris de
collecter avec votre association ces
témoignages de victimes pourquoi avoir
pris cette initiative il fallait faire
vite justement pour garder le plus
possible intactes ses témoignages
il fallait faire vite parce que les
témoins je dirais s'éparpille je donne
l'exemple d'une femme et qu'elle
habitait au 15e étage et s'était caché
dans un couloir missile est tombé dans
leur appartement elle a trouvé son fils
en mille morceaux comme elle dit et sa
fille qui n'avait plus plus de têtes
comme elle dit nous avons interviewé la
femme la seule survivante dans un
hôpital avec un petit éclat d'obus et
maintenant nous savons que sa santé se
désagrège donc nous courons je dirai
après le sauvetage des témoignages des
victimes civiles qui ont été tuées en
dehors du tout objectif militaire en
dehors de toute résidence administrative
par évidence on a affaire à des crimes
de guerre et des crimes contre
l'humanité comment est ce que vous
faites pour récolter ces témoignages
imagine que c'est un travail de fourmi
oui c'est un travail de fourmi un peu
semblables aux vôtres parfois c nous
avons des médiateurs qui entre en lien
par les dialogues sociaux avec ces gens
là où la famille et puis qui ouvre
le fait que la femme la personne accepte
de parler en zoom ce qui me fera
beaucoup c'est que chacun accepte de
parler à visage découvert de donner son
vrai nom sans téléphone sans adresse et
découvert avec stupeur le craignent que
dans chaque personne il y a comme un
résistant
avez vous réussi à recueillir des
témoignages de personnes qui viennent de
marioupol on rappelle cette ville est
assiégée depuis plus de deux mois
plusieurs milliers de civils y sont
toujours coincés et récemment des images
satellite ont révélé des fosses communes
notamment dans un village qui se trouve
à une vingtaine kilomètres de mario pas
là manouche
oui nous avons interrogé plusieurs
personnes qui sont sorties de mario paul
avant les derniers jours car on ne peut
plus sortir maintenant un monsieur est
allé même repérer les fosses communes
c'était le début des fosses communes
effectivement à se préparer à de grandes
fosses communes je pense à marioupol on
aura bien plus lire tabou de chat je ne
sais pas si les russes nous laisserons
constater la taille des dégâts là je
dirais on aura malheureusement des faits
très graves de crimes contre l'humanité
j'aurai dans son excellence la plupart
des victimes vous le disiez font cette
démarche de vous de vous parler elles
n'ont pas peur finalement ils n'ont pas
peur elles veulent témoigner cet
essentiel pour l a pas du tout on a les
choses les plus incroyables
on a un homme qu'ils ont arrêté dans la
rue ils l'ont aspergé d'essence et après
ils voulaient lui proposer une cigarette
pour montrer qu'ils allaient le tuer
finalement ils n'ont pas tué ils l'ont
habillé en soldat russe mis dans un char
immobile en essayant d'attirer d'attirer
des snipers ukrainien pendant plusieurs
jours comme ça n'a pas marché ils l'ont
relâché on a été moyen âge les plus
incroyables le pire sera la question des
viols je me rendrai très prochainement
en ukraine on a interviewé une personne
qui a sauvé 117 personnes et parmi ces
117 8 femmes qui avaient été choisies
comme pro fait par des militaires russes
et qui ont été violées dont l'une en
face de sa mère
on rappelle une une enquête de la cour
pénale internationale a été ouverte le 3
mars sur des allégations de crimes de
guerre et de crimes contre l'humanité en
ukraine le parquet ukrainien a aussi
ouvert une enquête tout comme onze états
membres de l'union européenne
hier en visite à moscou le secrétaire
général de l'onu antonio guterres as a
lui appelé à l'ouverture d'une enquête
indépendante sur ces possibles crimes de
guerre en ukraine les enquêtes se
multiplier cette essentielle ça aussi
puisque vous bien sûr vous travaillez à
recueillir ces témoignages mais il ya
d'autres associations et puis aussi tous
ces pays qui travaillent à recueillir
ces témoignages et toutes ses preuves ah
oui bien sûr gâteau toutes les
associations qui elle récolte par
exemple qu'ils images satellitaires
toutes les vidéos de propagande
toutes les images prises par les petits
téléphones annoncés une pièce du puzzle
nous savons que la justice mettra du
temps et que à la fin le procureur et le
juge dira est-ce qu'on a des témoins et
donc c'est là je dirais que on amène
notre part on est habitué à récolter les
témoignages de proximité ya de masse des
crimes de masse on se dépêche avec nos
réseaux ukrainiens dire et je vais me
rendre sur place pour mieux comprendre
l'ensemble situation
vous avez pu découvrir ces images de
boudhha comme le monde entier des images
de massacres des images très difficile à
supporter elles vous ont rappelé
d'autres scènes macabres qui ont marqué
l'histoire oui le des mêmes histoires
bocsa il y à bout de chaque été très
mise en valeur parce que c'est un visuel
et puéril mais il ya beaucoup de boue de
chats des petits villages autour un
monsieur est sorti avec son vélo par
exemple
et puis un chat à tirer qui lui arracher
une jambe les voisins ont réussi à
ligaturer la jambe il n'y avait pas
d'accès des secours le monsieur a
survécu on n'a eu d'autre exemple une
personne âgée aller acheter du pain
et elle lui a tiré dessus les mortes
dans la rue et les gens voyaient le
corps ne pouvait pas ramassés je dirais
il ya énormément de victimes civiles je
dirais que lui aux hasards
au hasard c'est comme des viols de
femmes de 15 ans une jeune fille de 15
ans avait une reprise comme trophée par
quinze militaires qui n'était pas au
combat qui étaient des jeunes militaires
n'étaient pas loin de 1000 et ils ont
violé pendant plusieurs jours ils l'ont
relâché quand ils sont partis au combat
on consent je dirais
l'autorisation de priscilla l'ordre
milliards valdo risation
merci beaucoup patrick desbois d'avoir
été avec nous et d'avoir répondu à
toutes nos questions